You might think confidence means being
big, bold, AND LOUD.
>> THE CHAMP
IS
>> BUT WHEN YOU LET GO OF THAT idea and do
the things that you think might make you
look weak,
>> I wasn't really good at being a son and
being a brother. I used to think I was
not enough. I did not value self.
>> That is when you become magnetic.
>> He seems like a very intelligent, nice
guy, but I love that he's that grounded.
>> He's also one of the greatest human
beings I've ever met.
>> He's so worth the hype. He's the best. I
love him.
>> So, we are going to break down the five
signs of secure confidence, using one of
the best examples that I have ever seen,
JOHN CENA.
>> DANG, LOT OF ENERGY IN THE ROOM. LOT OF
ENERGY.
FIRED UP.
>> BECAUSE WHAT he does is the exact
opposite of what most people think
[music] confidence looks like. But,
before we get there, we need to talk
about identity protection. You see, most
of us have a good idea of how we want to
others to see us. Maybe you want to be
the funny one in the group, or to be the
leader that people respect, or just
someone that is positive and fun to be
around. This all works fine until you
make that your whole identity. Because
when that identity is threatened, you
will either freeze or you'll bite back.
>> Monsters are dangerous, and just now
kings are dying like flies. I could have
your tongue out for saying that.
>> What you just saw is identity
protection. And this kind of reactivity,
it does not come across as true
confidence. People know that you're
trying to hide [music] something. And
when you suppress parts of yourself,
your life becomes a performance. And
then the fear comes creeping in.
Something terrible will happen if people
see every part of me. Once that fear is
there, it is very hard to shake. So,
what's the alternative?
>> It is really incredible to sit down and
[music] sense what kind of a true human
being you are with no veneer and amazing
proximity.
>> When you live your life with no veneer,
you're actually showing the parts of
yourself that almost everyone else edits
out. That is secure confidence. [music]
So, how do you build it? Well, the first
sign of secure confidence is enthusiasm.
>> A type of drink?
>> A Rob Roy.
>> What?
What?
>> No kid knows what a Rob Roy is?
>> They do now.
Rob Roy's for everybody.
>> everybody here. Uh
>> Now, enthusiasm might seem
counterintuitive because right now in
modern culture, there's a growing trend
that says that in order to be confident,
you need to be nonchalant.
>> Not displaying anxiety, interest,
[music] or enthusiasm.
>> Being nonchalant can help you as a man.
>> And I can see the appeal here.
Nonchalance looks like confidence on the
surface, but it won't make you feel
confident because actually you're
pretending [music] that you don't care
about anything, which is just another
form of identity protection. You're
suppressing your genuine reactions and
only showing people what you want them
to see. John Cena doesn't do that and he
isn't afraid to be seen enjoying
himself.
>> Our primetime is in the toilet. You're
not getting a cookie [laughter]
till this network comes up with a hit.
>> He's not managing how he looks or faking
enjoyment. He's just comfortable being
enthusiastic, honestly, even if the
people around him aren't. And that
enthusiasm is contagious. These big
reactions actually make the people
around him more expressive.
>> Donald Trump seems like a
larger-than-life figure. Do you think he
would do well in the world of
professional wrestling?
>> Stephen, do I?
>> Yeah. Yes.
>> So, the next time that you hear a joke
that is genuinely funny or a question
that surprises you, let your full
reaction through. You'll make the other
person feel heard and more importantly,
you will prove to yourself that your
unfiltered reactions are good enough.
And feeling that you're good enough is
the essence of secure confidence. That
brings us to the second sign, which is
silliness.
>> No way.
Nah, nah.
>> Okay.
>> Now, it's easy to dismiss this type of
humor as just goofing around, but it
actually requires very high levels of
confidence. For instance, ask yourself,
what is the most ridiculous outfit that
you have ever worn? Maybe it's something
that you wore to a costume party or
during a school play or you dressed up
for Halloween. Now, picture yourself
wearing that crazy costume to work and
you're the only one in the room that is
actually dressed up. Everyone else there
is just in their regular clothes. Would
you have the confidence to do that? Now,
some of you probably think that you
could handle that, so let's turn it up a
notch. Forget your costume. Would you
dress up like this? And would you have
the confidence to dance around in front
of a studio audience while you're
wearing it? And for the few of you who
are still thinking, "I could do that, no
problem." I have one more question.
Would you step out in front of the most
important people in your industry at the
most prestigious event of the year
wearing nothing but sandals and an
[music] envelope, all just to get a
quick laugh?
>> Costumes,
they are so important.
>> Being on stage naked is a literal
nightmare for most people, and yet John
Cena volunteered to do it. He's
confident enough to stand up in front of
people that are just as likely to laugh
at him as they are to laugh with him.
How did he get that?
>> Be naked in front of everybody?
>> Yeah, no problem. Let's do it. So, that
also comes with like, "Well, people are
going to laugh at me, and people are
going to make fun of the way I look
physically."
Okay, man. Let's go. Being okay with
self.
>> He's willing to make himself the butt of
the joke because he knows that that
embarrassment doesn't define him. Now,
you don't have to stand in front of a
crowd completely naked. You can start
training this muscle by telling your own
embarrassing stories. Doesn't have to be
anything that you're super ashamed of,
just a story where you didn't look
perfect and that you can look back at
now and laugh at.
>> You were starting off in wrestling. You
had a persona, sort of half man, half
machine. Was that the idea?
>> Yes, it was.
>> This was prototype.
>> It was awful.
>> [laughter]
>> My first try was the prototype, which
was half man and half machine, and 100%
crap.
>> One thing to watch out for here, it is
possible to overuse embarrassing or
self-deprecating jokes. If this is the
only kind of humor that you're using, it
can become just another form of identity
protection. I'm going to name my flaws
before anyone else has the chance. So,
it's important to be able to express
genuine pride in your achievements as
well. You can watch how John Cena does
this in this next clip where he's
talking about his rap album.
>> Do you listen to the album ever?
>> I do. Every year I try to listen to it.
I'm very proud of it.
>> Will there be a follow-up? Is there
going to be a 20-year anniversary
celebration for the album?
>> [laughter]
>> When you are able to acknowledge both
your successes and your shortcomings,
you come across as supremely confident.
And speaking of owning your mistakes,
the next sign of secure confidence is
shadow sharing. John Cena is comfortable
opening up about the things that most
people would leave in their shadow.
>> It brought light some of my
shortcomings, the fact that I am very
difficult to deal with, the fact that I
have a lot of rules. There are days
where getting to be John Cena, the
backpack is heavy.
>> Now, a lot of people, especially young
men, believe that they need to hide
their struggles in order to be liked and
respected.
>> But you cried. There were tears that ran
down my face, but I did not cry.
>> I mean, that's crying.
>> I would disagree.
>> Now, that's an extreme example, but
we've all done a subtle version of this.
Maybe it's changing the subject when a
difficult topic comes up, or pretending
to be fine when you're actually going
through a hard time. You're denying your
emotions and your struggles. And this
is, you guessed it, another form of
identity protection. You're hiding the
bad, so people only ever see the good.
But when John Cena opens up to someone,
when he shares his shadow, the people
around him open up, too.
>> There's not a time that I've ever walked
around that door that I'm not nervous.
>> I do think you know how valuable that
is. That's helping me right now because
I'm scared in this job all the time.
>> Everybody struggles. And by naming it
first, you give the room permission to
share something they never thought they
could admit. Not only does this deepen
your connections, you become the
conversational leader.
>> It's something I used to feel
uncomfortable in rooms like this, in
front of people.
>> I did, too. I did, too. Early on, I was
exhilarated because I thought this is
scared the scariest thing you could do.
>> When you talk about the hard stuff
without flinching, you show the room
something that they don't often see,
that you don't need to be perfect in
order to feel good about yourself. Now,
you will know that you are deep into
secure confidence if you have this next
very very trait. And honestly, this is
the entire reason that I wanted to make
this John Cena video in the first place.
He embodies selflessness. When you stop
trying to control how people see you,
something shifts. Your attention is free
to move outward. So, your perspective
changes.
>> Cuz I was like, "Oh, I Don't you hate it
when people are like, 'I can't see
you.'" He was like, "No, Nicole. That's
what people know about me. They're just
trying to connect. When they say it to
me, I'm happy cuz they're taking it in
and they like me. And that's nice, isn't
it?"
>> How you speak to people changes.
>> Well, hey, you guys always cheer for the
guest. FOR JIMMY, PAL.
>> AND HOW YOU RESPOND TO PEOPLE ASKING for
something changes.
>> I'm going through cancer, stage four.
>> Okay.
>> I wanted to know if I could hug you or
see you.
>> Absolutely.
>> John Cena has granted [music] more than
650 wishes for wish children.
>> There's someone
>> [music]
>> fighting some circumstances
and the one thing they'd like to do is
hang out with you. Do you have time for
that? 100% [music] we're going to do
that.
>> John Cena holds the Guinness Book of
World Records for the most Make-A-Wish
has given an immense amount of his time
to people who cannot repay him. And
there's nothing that he says he finds
more rewarding.
>> And it's an absolute blur. Whatever you
think you give to somebody, they give
back to you exponentially.
>> Now, this isn't some strategy to be
charismatic. It flows naturally when you
stop trying to show your best to people
and instead be your best for them.
Because when you feel good about who you
are, you naturally want to spread that
feeling to others. And this brings us to
the final sign of secure confidence. And
this is the one that ties everything
else together. It's range. John Cena's
superpower is that he can move
effortlessly between enthusiasm, shadow
sharing, silliness, and selflessness. He
doesn't get stuck in one mode.
>> I haven't seen you in a while, Cena.
>> How's your life been?
>> I wanted to go out there with my
incredibly underwhelming odd-shaped
penis just in the way.
>> [laughter]
>> So, you gave me a a chance, an
opportunity to stand in front of people
who inspire me and who my admire. I
didn't necessarily reap all the rewards
of getting the fun, but it wasn't about
what I wanted. It was about making the
bit good.
>> When you have secure confidence, you can
be playful, and then sincere, and then
vulnerable, and then funny, and sad, and
strong, deep, overwhelmed. It doesn't
matter, because secure confidence knows
that we all have these experiences, and
it's okay to express them without having
them define you. So, the best way to
develop range is not by trying to do all
of these things at once. That would
probably just get you feeling stuck.
It's by focusing on just one slightly
challenging mode at a time. So, my
challenge to you today is this. Take
time to pick just one of these
characteristics and make space to
express it in your day. You can be more
enthusiastic when you're greeting a
co-worker, or send a random text to a
friend letting them know that you
appreciate them. Or you can share a
story where you don't come across like
the hero. Just pick the one of these
that feels a bit like a stretch and
commit to doing it just [music] once.
Because if you keep this practice up for
a week, you will have developed a range
that most people would blush at. And
this philosophy of simple, daily actions
is exactly how I have always worked on
my confidence and my charisma. I started
scared to speak up in groups of five
friends, and now I'm sharing my thoughts
with all of you. So, this approach
works. I know it. And if you want to
commit to these daily actions to grow
your confidence and your charisma, the
fastest way that I know, you may be
interested in joining Charisma
University. Here is what just a few of
the members have to say about it. I was
always a party killer. After completing
the course, I'm already called the life
of the party, and old school mates tell
me I'm a completely different person.
Charisma University helped me to turn on
my charismatic side like a button. I
started to talk with this girl that is
today my girlfriend. I went from this
very weird person who missed social cues
to this guy that could keep a
conversation going and make people
laugh. Now, tens of thousands students
have gone through Charisma University.
It's 30 days, hand-held, step-by-step,
fully guaranteed. And if you don't think
the course is worth it, you can get a
full refund right from inside the
program. Like it's on the screen and in
the description. Either way, I hope that
you've enjoyed this video, and I look
forward to seeing you in the next one.